please be a bullet in you
welcome back to Endo parasitic everyone
um
I didn't expect that to happen uh do I
have bullets okay I do okay I have
bullets in you at least
um
right
oh no no oh
hi
all right well this is interesting
um we got back in here in a hurry and I
was not ready for any of that
okay we're good on that
any more of you [ __ ]
how many more of you [ __ ]
oh that's not good
hello
scratchy
what's going on oh
ah but I need oh but I needed
oh but I need to save my God but I need
to save my God
I need to save my yo
oh god oh frick okay
oh I missed oh I missed no no not like
this oh well I'm just gonna go for it
okay hold on
this is going extremely poorly
you know how I said that I was good at
this game it turns out
I'm not
I'm not okay
ah got two bullets left I it used to be
a bonanza
it used to be a bonanza
but then it turned into a disaster
I don't know what to do and I'm
extremely Burpy because I just chugged a
soda before I got here and I don't know
what's going on
oh man
music
oh that's a bit of a change why
[Music]
contamination detected do not consumer
wash please attend a water source
immediately why why music so much and so
now when you were not before
weird
I'm guessing I must have entered another
chapter or something because this is the
only reason that they would do something
like that
am I even gonna be able to hear any
squeaks as a
around the corners doesn't even seem
like anything was over here there's no
dead bodies no blood on the ground
I thought they were dead until one took
a chunk out of my ankle move slowly step
carefully and make as little noise as
you can
what
what
do you mean I don't have feet
I don't I don't have feet
is this important
oh
wait a minute
hold on a second
hold on a second
what was that clawed hand I just saw
what
oh no
oh my God are you kidding me
[Music]
I'm not gonna touch any part of you
oh my God
oh
foreign
oh no I don't know if they actually
would have woken up
well it's a good thing I didn't cough
when I was near him it's a really good
thing
it's an exceptionally good thing
man I don't know if I was like literally
inches away from death
oh oh please
at least that didn't wake him up or if
they can be woken up it all might be a
ruse
might be a ruse
might be a big old ruse
and moved
it moved
you see that did I waste a shotgun shell
or were there two of them it moved it
moved his hand
oh it moved it moved all right
well that's not good
I had a feeling there would be something
up here
it's Gotta Move nice and slowly
oh God
okay I'm full up on these bullets I do
need them
oh man this this uh game
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm dead
okay
so I just gotta move very carefully all
the time because they are
everywhere they're not dead well they're
not a lot they're not dead
or maybe they are
I don't know
and I I am running so low on materials
how do I get by you oh God
don't
it's just you and me buddy we're just
two dead bodies
don't worry about a thing
very dead
very dead
oh extremely dead bodies
just the deadest of dead
so not alive
Joe
I swear it looks like they're moving but
it's just the Parallax motion as I'm
going by
but it do look like they're moving
but they're not
but maybe they are
hey pal do you want to hold hands
oh
oh
okay
we're okay for now
I'm just gonna assume that there are
more of those things everywhere
I hear something breathing though so
it's a walking type
yep
nice
come on
some some part of me just wishes I only
had the revolver and they would only
give me a roll of Oliver because all
these different weapons have just made
everything so much more complicated than
they were everything was simple when it
was just a revolver
oh really God of course you would of
course you would
oh my God never mind even if I had the
revolver I would manage to [ __ ] it up I
would manage to [ __ ] it up I would
manage to [ __ ] it up somehow I just
would
because that's just what I do now that
I'm absolutely convinced that these
parasites are both Discerning and
intelligent it is clear that they came
to me for a reason once I'm able to
establish the effects of their infection
and unworthy host bodies no one will be
able to stop me I'm worthy who if not me
it knows I would do anything for the
pursuit of Science of conviction this is
my purpose praise be to null my god of
Science of absence
thing is trying to kill me when I should
have been its host it's Ally
uh-huh yeah
um about that
so uh why do I even wanna
push myself to survive oh no limbed that
I am
where are you I know you're here
got him
looks like naul didn't want to didn't
want to make me uh
friend you know
looks like null uh kind of abandoned me
I don't know why I'm mocking myself like
I can actually do anything about it
okay we're good there
all right they loaded me up for a reason
I'm not looking forward to the why of it
oh boy here we go
yeah
yeah okay save that for the remaining
rats if there are any
you get one nope you get bam
oh my goodness you know part of me wants
to go back in this game once I've played
through it once and just kind of oh
really no way oh what have you had for
me and kind of see if I can do it again
but even better like this seems like the
kind of game where I would want to
replay it and just see if I could do
less ass because in the beginning
in the beginning of this I was real not
ass added
it was probably shocking to you guys
that I seem somewhat competent
oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
what is with the heavy breathing
oh
that's some heavy breathing
are you sleeping
is that some honk me me me me
is that some call me me me me me
someone's sleeping here
foreign
legits you sleeping in here
through this disaster
who
I don't want to know who's hunk me me
[Music]
I don't like hunk me me me
I don't want to know
it really sounds like someone's snoozing
Uh something's wrong all of a sudden the
monkey started pounding on the glass of
their containment well if I locked you
in a glass box we wouldn't like it
either would you it's different than
that more panicked now the security
guard collapsed he's he's mutating oh
God so this is disastrous are you there
yeah
um
wow
wow
oh my God hey inventory
well that's handy
okay
easy there
easy there buddy
easy these are some Big Boys these are
some big big boys
there's not a big big boy in this one
I'm kind of concerned about that
nailed it not enough space though I
think the flare has one in it yeah so I
got plenty of flair oh hey
so if I have plenty of flair that means
I should probably use flare on whatever
the biggest thing would be
which is probably the thing in there
and again don't know why I'd want to
nailed it
and there's another one around here
somewhere
oh God damn it
ah always always like that
okay at least I can heal the damage
good good good no no no no no no no no
no no no I ain't no coward look if
you're in here telling me that they're
well hey big guy hey
if you're here telling me that there's
things that need killing I'm gonna kill
him and you gave me enough flare to kill
them so I'm gonna kill them
how do I kill them
how do I kill them
ow oh you God damn you
damn you
wrong with you what if I maybe I don't
waste one of these on it
oh no
no
[Music]
no
no that was a waste of bullets okay
so that was a waste
you're a waste
if I sneak by I can get bullets back
so why is this one open is the question
and maybe it'll have me coming back I
don't know
it seems very strange
no
it probably has me coming back there's
no way I'm done with that right
oh God why God's name's happened to you
never mind there's no time the airlock
is broken from this side if you could
just if I let you out those things will
get out as well I don't think it's a
very wise risk to take no no please
tell me what you know about the outbreak
pravi well I I saw one of the airtight
containers we used to transport the
specimens by the decontamination chamber
someone intentionally released the
parasites through the oxygen system so
it was premeditated
it's rather fortunate that we had your
vaccines then
what are you implying only three people
in this facility had access to my
research and if it wasn't Lucy and it
wasn't you do you think I let them out
you were the one considering a mass
infection you got what you wanted didn't
you may the gods have mercy on you
probably
oh no wait wait
[Applause]
why is that in my left ear
the developer found a ball
[Laughter]
well uh good thing that thing was
waiting for me to say my uh
final goodbye parasite mutations have
caused loss of sight which in turn has
led to an increase in sensitivity to
sound all right good to know
good no honk me me me me me
I'm just gonna you know what I'm not
gonna go towards the big breathing I'm
gonna see if it's here oh no no holy
crap no
what
oh it's a good thing that I during that
oh no
no no no
oh my god
when was the last time I saved I don't
know oh my God no
foreign
why is that thing so fast
that's not cool bro
that's not cool
stop coughing please stop coughing you
gotta stop coughing so much you gotta
stop
now is not the time
now is so extremely not I almost walked
into that thing the first time I mean I
know I died do it but I almost I almost
walked right into it
stop coughing
please stop coughing
oh boy
oh
[Music]
my god
oh okay all right well that's not good
okay so this is a problem
[Music]
I don't know how sensitive it is to
sound when someone okay I'm not close so
it's got to be a less sensitive right
so how
does this help me
if
oh God
oh God you're so near to me
oh my God
hmm
I just go I just go I just go I just go
I just go that's the only answer I just
go
oh
are you silai Lila Lent
are you a silai island you're scyll
Island are you ah wine crank until it
clicks Place bolt into Groove pull
trigger to fire
okay wine crank until it clicks
come on this way
okay Place bolt okay
and it's ready to go
good
good
why good I don't know
I was risky in case one of those things
but I didn't hear breathing I didn't
hear no honk me me me me I see you
though
and maybe I can retrieve the crossbow
bolts
what if I do this
[Laughter]
are you dead oh you're not dead
oh well that's hardly fair
at least I do get it back though you
guys suck
I hope you know that
oh boy
and and
that's too close though I don't like it
oh you guys are awful this is awful this
is awful this is awful and I don't know
why not shooting you guys doesn't work
what what what what no no what's
happening
save okay
okay okay
oh please oh no no no no no ah come on
no oh
damn you damn you damn you damn you as
soon as I get health you got you gotta
take it away from me
oh my God
oh my God
come on
oh my God
okay I don't hear any more scratchies
okay that's good for that okay good
holy crap oh my God
[Music]
no
no
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] wait wait
ow oh what the ball uh well uh well oh
oh okay
all right
that was unfortunate
got him
okay
nice very nice well handled almost
expertly handled as one might say
incredibly handled
okay
that leaves me not nearly where I was
before that's actually marginally better
and you guys do not do the thing that
you were doing
I'm just gonna get close enough so I can
start going away
okay
wait you come back
what where are you
hello
you were coming after me what happened
what happened
what happened
where are you where are you
what's happening
there there there
one more blam
okay as remiss as I am to lose those I I
just doesn't feel like douching around
on that
okay nice and easy nice and easy nice
easy breezy Breezy
easy breezy easy breezy
easy breezy Breezy
all right
I know they're probably going to stick
me with that big thing sooner rather
than later who loaded this thing
all right I'm ready
no
oh no
at least I didn't get hit okay
you guys are everywhere aren't you
yeah
yeah
yeah
oh god oh oh God damn it did I hit it
there's no way
there's no way did I hit that thing no
way no way
oof not the best but not the worst
I don't know what that did
I don't know what that did
huh
oh
did I get it
I think so
I heard a squeak I just don't know if
that was a squeak of guaranteed kill
yeah I got it okay so there's three
there's one oh God where oh
somehow somehow across the shoulder
across the shoulder okay that's all the
scratches that I hear oop that's not
what I wanted
uh okay
all right let me rewind this
I know I wasn't using this and I know
this would be incredibly useful but I
didn't so
that's just all I have to say about that
okay but I opened them up
I hear more
the crossbow bolt though
uh save I guess
man more uh more uh
flares but it's like I don't really know
what I'm gonna do with flares I haven't
even spent the flares I have
oh boy damn it oh God kill me kill me
just kill me
oh there's no way I'm letting that that
fly
you got him
oh God I almost shot myself in the head
that's fun
oh boy that's not good
hey you don't want to see that oh you
don't want to see this either
Bobby yeah okay nice and easy
another fun room for everyone to hide
under
somehow oh boy
hey whoa I did not move fast at all why
you got to be dick hey hey stop it
you're an [ __ ] you're an [ __ ]
I was not moving fast even remotely
I was not even remotely moving quickly
that is Harsh [ __ ]
or [ __ ]
horse [ __ ]
still not to the point where I could
confidently do a combat reload of that
but
not the worst
hey hey stop it it's a real dick move
I don't know oh oh there we go
I kind of forgot that the crossbow was
silent there for a second there in the
back of my mind I didn't know
but also part of me was like in the in
the Instinct that I have to shoot him
with the pistol because that's what you
do
oh that's not a good sound
how close is Mr honk me me me
how close is Mr honk me me me
I don't hear him anymore
which is very weird
I kind of hear him
just don't hear him very much
laughs
oh come on
no no no no oh come on
no come on oh my God I'm not even gonna
heal I'm not gonna bother the
embarrassment the embarrassment
horrible
okay so far so good
controlled calm
calmly
nailed it
good thing they put lights on these
things
okay that opens something
oh I hear honk me me me
foreign
I hear you
nice that went well
foreign
ly good so far
surprisingly good so far
love this crossbow so much
the idea
of it is beautiful
it is fascinating and incredible
but I have a funny feeling that when I
open this up
suddenly there's going to be a big guy
in here
that was all four right
oh honk me me
oh
my god did they leave or something oh no
it's just in here isn't it
that looks like a crossbow is that not
gonna crossbow I can get oh just in case
I lost one apparently oh good the
crossbow bolts in the wall all over the
place oh good
what is the deal here oh boy
oh you sound close
doorway sealed until biohazard
eliminated
yeah okay
what Biohazard
what biohazard we talking about here is
it in the center of the room
is it in the center
[Music]
oh God what do you mean
what did you just do
oh God my best bet would probably be to
get in the center-ish of the room
oh it's so hard to judge I think this
would be the center
no is this the center
unless it's not in the center unless
it's more like the top quadrant
I don't know where it is
oh my God
it's where I shot before
crudino
oh my God okay
I think it was right here
holy crap I didn't like that at all
this is terrible this is terrible I hate
this
well I missed it
oh it is down here still
oh it is down here still
oh that's not good
what did I miss
Ed I killed it no way no way no way
three is all it whoa
oh hey big guy
[Laughter]
let me through
wow I can't believe that worked
how did that work I don't know what what
is this what's the pyramid floor this
can't be good to walk on welcome we are
so pleased to have you visiting our fine
lab do not hesitate to ask me for
anything you might need
before entering their locked doors
please make sure you're up to date on
all Safety and Security protocols due to
this strictly confidential nature of the
research we do here no nextupkin will be
notified of any injuries accidents or
fatalities that may occur during your
visit we appreciate your understanding
Lucy
okay that is nice I guess except it's
abrading my underbelly but whatever
that's fine I'm fine with this
I'm all right with this I'm okay with
this
all this is a-okay
righty hoe
what
what what
huh
[Music]
that's some kind of mutated plan or
something
I don't know what the deal is with that
but all right
[Music]
where'd you come from
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
interesting
all right I'm good still not enough
space for that
but haven't had a need to use anything
but the crossbow for a while
because it is just that good I don't
know where it is or where it's coming
from or how it's getting in or oh Gods
it's back I can hear it it just keeps
showing up if you find this please know
that I
I don't know what that means I don't
like what that means I don't like the
insinuation of what that means I don't
like anything about what that means what
is what what's the deal
what do you mean
I don't like this
oh oh oh oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
what in the hell
what
how what how'd that happen
what this is really weird okay
interesting so sometimes they contain
another monster
nope nope got oh
oh well Frick okay I [ __ ] that up
not my fault not my fault not my fault
not my fault
man it's like if I try to do the
crossbow too fast it just never works
which is interesting
good save game
I'm just gonna shoot him
did I kill them did I kill the rat in it
oh there was a rat in it okay
oh
don't know why the furniture started to
turn into those things but
oh well
geez what's his
interesting
oh really
the one the one round that I didn't have
that needed to be had gone
oh you oh you lovely lovely thing you
God I love you love that and love you
dude love that love that so lovely that
I shouldn't have wasted that many
bullets on that
but I did
okay did that hurt me no
I can whack in them whoa
what in the Fresh House
was oh
what what the frick what was that
what was that oh my God
oh my God are you kidding me what
what the [ __ ]
wow
are you dead
did I get you
are you mad are you upset you mad bro
you mad
oh frick why
foreign
God what is what is this bullet what is
this bullet situation
whoa whoa what in the world are you
kidding me wait you're still here since
when
since when
oh my God are you kidding me
nope not that oh God
damn it God damn it
no oh God
why are you not dead
how is this thing not dead I've lost my
crossbows no I've got him
this is weird and I don't know why it's
happening and I don't know how it's not
dead yet but it's not don't know what's
happening
[Music]
no oh my God are you kidding me oh frick
off you're gonna hit me at least kill
these things too
damn it
okay all right so there's no killing
this thing right it's just gonna keep
doing this I think anyway
whoa whoa whoa okay yeah this thing is
just gonna keep doing this so I'm gonna
use it to my advantage
holy [ __ ] yeah that's right try oh why
are you no no no no no no rat no rat oh
no rat rat rat rat rat
oh I'm out of Health oh I'm out of
Health give me health health please no
no not this
no no no no
[Music]
oh God put it away all right well
there's that then
okay
[Music]
I'm gonna die because I'm gonna bleed
out or not bleed out but the equivalent
of a parasite getting into my brain you
know something like that that's gonna
occur to me that's gonna happen
this is just too dicey
wow that's a lot of stuff this would be
great if you could give me some health
as well no all right
man that thing's really close to my
brain sure would be nice to get some
health health Blues Health please Health
please Health oh first contact with
parasites I want to start documenting
like probably they pay me no mind I'm
sure I need to know if my vision was
real I need some kind of contact with
them so I decided to stay late one night
and operate a drone to bring my scarf
over to the research facility I wanted
them to know me even if I can't be with
them I watched through the remote camera
as a little bug swarm the scarf I felt
foolish all of a sudden seeing them
they're just insects they can't pick and
choose people but they started to pull
at the threads breaking them and
rearranging the red fabric until the
there were holes in it the hole spelled
out a
wordless she's Reckless I have half a
mind to report her to the research board
uh isn't that a little
isn't it a little late
oh but no but now it's oh it's gonna be
gone oh man but I did all the no
oh I missed it
didn't I did I miss
all right I'm just assuming I didn't
miss
I didn't miss
oh I've got half a mind to report her to
the authorities I'm gonna write a
sternly worded letter to her supervisor
me and I'm gonna have a thing or two to
say about that report once I read it not
only is she bring us she's Reckless I
have half of mind to report her to the
research board
I have half a mind a shooter
hello
you know what I'm uh I'm gonna not play
around with this other one never mind
yes I will
God I'm about to die
all this is gonna be for nothing if I
can't get some health please have health
you didn't have health at all you had
the opposite of Health
damn you oh it's going right to my brain
it's going right to my brain my brain is
being invaded everybody my brain's being
invaded four inventory slots is cool
though I got bag Master whatever that
means oh
frick my dick all right this time not
fooling around boosh all right that's
great okay good going for it well you're
dead good all right this is great oh not
enough space that's all right
because I'm gonna reload this gun
then I'll have space for sure
that's great then I'm gonna take this
out of here and put that in there and
I'm gonna put that away and then I'm
gonna grab more of those and then I'm
gonna go over here and then I'm gonna
shoot him with a bow and I'm gonna wind
this son of a [ __ ] and then I'm gonna
put it over there and well I'm gonna put
another bulletin in then I'm gonna put a
bow on my back again I'm gonna go over
here and then I'm gonna come over here
and I'm gonna prepare for this by
grabbing this and yo yo oh [ __ ] wow
I'm gonna go through here grab that here
gonna pick pick this gun up and I'll put
this here gonna put this here I'll put
that in there and I'm gonna grab some
rubber rounds I'll never have this and
I'm gonna put this in here and then I'm
done with that and then I spin it around
then I go over here and then I go to
town right now
hey give me this and then give me that
and then put that right in there hey no
no going over here and I'm going right
there hey
everybody
hop on that and put it back in my head
[Music]
everybody
there's another there bang bang it's
grabbing there's a bang in the door but
the babadook watch out there and round
it rounded boy another bolt all right
I'm done I'm done with this nonsense
English sub shop
all right put that there
[Music]
we go one more time oh my God right now
oh my God take that out
oh that way go right here I had to grab
another flare right there grab a handle
here
in here one into a three four and five
and then you're done
[Music]
foreign
run by me all right
are you all dead now are you actually
all dead
God there wasn't even any health in
there
what do we have
saved that was a terrible idea because
I'm about to die oh hey what's up
hey what's up I'm going for it oh God
I'm going for it oh I should have saved
a flare for here well [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's okay because he's not chasing after
me right now so I can open up the thing
and then I can put another flare and
then I get another flare right there and
then
if I remember which one it was what but
I don't remember at all it seems
different right now oh God
foreign
there
flare right here grab another flare go
over here fastest I can I'm going to die
oh my God please oh no oh no save for
some reason oh frick here we go
oh frick oh frick oh there's an oh frick
give give give give give put it in my
brain oh my God I'm alive I'm alive safe
safe safe
put it in my brain
oh
miss me oh no oh that was a mouse ah
that was a problem no well I might as
well die oh might as well die because
that was poor planning on my part
didn't account for the rats well what
the hell happened there
what the hell was that I don't even know
is this full
it's not
that was my problem oh right I forgot
about you right I forgot that you were
an issue
uh-huh just going for it just going for
it okay I'm not going for it because I'm
stuck wow that oh my God here I am again
stuck in a goddamn hell of my own making
what have I done to myself what is wrong
with me I have just gone terrible
oh you're go away go away I'm not ready
for you I'm not ready for any of you
everything's going horribly
I can't sustain it I can't sustain it is
that gonna be is this gonna be I don't
still don't know
is this going to go here to there I
think I think I think oh man I don't
know
oh man
oh man
hello
wow nice computers
air Roar
air Roar
okay I can't stop picturing the word
they carved into my scarf I had to
incinerate it but I hold their message
in my heart you they said I read all of
blue and pravey's research on the
creatures wrote about an anomaly who was
chosen by the parasites to be kept alive
turned into a God is that my purpose
here am I an anomaly I've never quite
felt like I belong here probably doesn't
pay me any minded literally treats me
like a clueless child I'm more than that
even if I'm not an intellectual I belong
here I'll show them that
how clueless oh
great great oh my arm is just so
[Music]